she is considered the new hope of the
Turkish opposition Sarah queda Gill sits
on the board of the Social Democratic
Party the CHP with twenty-five percent
of the vote it is the largest opposition
party in the Turkish Parliament three
years ago the young lawyer was fighting
for the preservation of Istanbul's gezi
Park a dispute that became a power
struggle between the opposition and the
air dhawan government today queda Gil
sees the chances of the opposition
winning power waning fast Vantiv is
there no one in the opposition parties
even we in the CHP could ever have
imagined that the political situation
here would have declined so quickly we
tried to pretend that we're still able
to make changes as if we have normal
political competition among the parties
but this is a system that doesn't care
about the rule of law and the
Constitution said the allegation that
the opposition is not doing enough is
unfair categor complains that the
president tries to control all aspects
of daily life even Istanbul's building
policy is controlled when Aaron's Palace
this she says has nothing to do with
democracy air Dhawan wants to make his
mark with mega projects such as building
a new airport the third in Istanbul he
wants it to be the largest airport in
the world with the current system in
place air Dhawan will accumulate even
more power critics within his party are
gradually being pushed aside people such
as Abdul Latif Cheniere shaniya was a
founder of the ruling AKP party and
served as deputy prime minister from
2002 to 2007 today he says there is no
one in the AKP capable of challenging
air21 yeah it keeps yes we started as a
party with a management team not an
autocrat now air Dhawan is not only
sidelined the Democratic consensus of
the party but also the constitution of
this country no one can call this a
democratic leadership Democratic Beauty
derelict in there shush it ma is there
are very few remaining media outlets
available to the opposition social near
seldom has a chance to give interviews
and under air to one's government the
versity teacher is no longer able to
find work Beulah Hobbit university's
first say they'll hire me then send a
letter explaining that they are sorry
but they're not able to offer me a
position this has happened seven times
already betis tamia someone has given an
order to prevent me from working at
Turkish universities well no agent
Leonard rejects it this year the
opposition parties are paralyzed should
president era de juan become the
absolute ruler of turkey they also fear
political extinction